so i started this debt business of mine
back in 2003.
right
i don't run it anymore my brother runs
it um i'm just an advisor but founded
this thing back in 2003.
it was a roller coaster ride it was it
it almost didn't happen and it almost
got taken out
um
do i still have it in here
almost got taken out
got featured in uh
front page of the business section
january 19th
let me just put it for put it in front
of you some somebody paid about twenty
thousand dollars to put that little
square ad over there
i paid nothing to have them put me on
the front page of the toronto star
business section we got a lot of
business off that there was a lot that i
learned in
that business that i ran it's um
something that i'm proud of it lasted
for a long time while i ran it and still
continues to
to roll but 2003
was a start date and
what it did is it basically negotiates
your credit card balance is between the
creditor and the debtor
and um
collection agencies were doing this for
ages um somebody would
have 30 40 50 000 worth of credit card
debt assigned to an agency and sometimes
there was some negotiation work done but
we but we took it to a whole new level
it just went full-on professional
and um we brokered the deal between the
debtor and the creditor
so most of the business during that time
came from
our um mortgage agents let me just see
if i can turn this thing on over here
there we go
we're gonna stand up i always tell
better stories when i stand up all right
here we go
let's do this
so we used to
get most of our business from creditors
um
that needed settlement through mortgage
agents and they have a unique problem so
to do a mortgage on a property you have
to have a certain amount of equity we'll
just use a hundred thousand dollars to
keep it simple
so
if a property is worth a hundred
thousand dollars and your mortgage
balance is sixty thousand dollars that
means you've got forty thousand dollars
in equity and the loan to value on that
property is 60
so you can borrow against any
differences at the time
um they would usually do an 80 to 85
percent ltv which all that really meant
was you know if the if the current first
mortgage was 60 grand a second uh
mortgage would get placed on the
property for the difference up to about
an 85 percent ltb
so another 25 000 might you know get
pulled out of that property let's say
but if they had 50 000 in debt you
couldn't get rid of all the debt with
the mortgage financing and the mortgage
lender didn't really want to lend the
money unless all the debt was paid off
so there was two problems there the
lender wouldn't lend on the deal and
they'd lose a lending opportunity and
the debtor wouldn't be able to
pay off the credit card debt
so i was like all right well we can
broker the deal between the two because
i know how to do this and i have enough
contacts and i can make this happen so i
built the business around that
and i did that primarily getting most of
our clients from mortgage agents so i
basically go to the mortgage industry
and i'm giving you the complete cheat
code here to what i did to run this
business um
there's also a book that i wrote that's
on
amazon from 2010 i think
i'll pull
so at the screen
uh
is that no
that's not here we go this is it over
here that's the right one
add a stream um
so
it's just called enough is enough the
diy dead settlement guide so everything
in this book over here it's only
available as kindle i never did it as as
a print because i didn't really care at
the time but everything in here is
basically what we did from day one all
the way through the entire settlement
process so i gave away the cheat code to
settling your own debt um some would be
like oh why would you do that give away
the you know the secret sauce but
there's a lot more to it than just like
the steps that were involved there was
some back end work that you really had
to have the skills for it's like you
know you can t you can say 100 meter
swim is from here to here all you have
to do is go from there to there but
there's a lot of technique that's
learned behind the scenes so you're
really not giving away the farm when you
write a book with
all the steps in it but anyway
um
so
we're doing a ton of these settlements
mortgage agents are giving us business
and generally speaking we're doing
anywhere from
six to ten thousand dollars in the high
end and most of these deals we get done
in about two to three weeks and i think
we're probably doing about thirty
thousand dollars a month in sales
receipts at that time just got a brand
new office
um it was it was uh it was on the third
story of this like century home in
richmond hill which is in the outskirts
of toronto
um there's a psychiatrist on the main
floor and i think a physiotherapist in
the basement
so
bringing in deals i'm doing all the
deals i'm doing a lot of the negotiating
um i've got my brother in the business
doing some sales and another guy who is
also doing some sales and this chick
that was doing some of the negotiation
work with us and uh it went along pretty
well for quite a few years from 2003 to
2005 until
i had this guy
who was one of the biggest deals i ever
took on from one of the larger
mortgage agents that i had a great
relationship with and they lived out in
oakville i think which at the time was
one of the more expensive houses so back
in
2005 or so one of these places might
have been
i don't know three and a half million or
something like that which was quite a
lot at the time for that neighborhood
and um
got this deal that was going to pay out
about fifteen thousand dollars in
fees i think in in total so got started
got it all done uh pretty quickly within
about three to four weeks mortgage was
supposed to close proceeds were supposed
to go from the mortgage lender to the
creditors via the settlements that i
negotiated in writing and i uh had this
guy who
i didn't i hadn't been burned by anybody
by by by that point in time okay
and um
all i remember was calling the lawyer's
office later on that day and i'm like
hey i heard the creditors got paid out
but i haven't seen the transfer yet for
the uh the fees
and then the lawyer goes oh the borrower
got a hold of the money and i go what do
you mean he goes yeah you're going to
call him and this is the first time that
this had happened we had done maybe
30
35 deals you know prior to that never
happened prior
and then um
call the guy up and he [ __ ] tells me
to go pound sand
he's like yeah i'm not gonna pay you i'm
like dude
i just saved you like seventy thousand
dollars negotiating with all your credit
he's like and he just hung up the phone
i was like what the [ __ ]
i couldn't believe it i was like
there's there's actually people out
there that would do something like that
like
have somebody work their ass off for
three weeks and then not pay them and
then
just take what you've done for them for
free i was like that is
i was pissed
i was that was probably one of the only
times in my life that i had ever
considered
harming somebody really badly like
starting to think about ways like
you know how do i make this person know
that what they had done is not
acceptable and they should never do it
again i was like no man this is like i
got to the point where i was talking to
my brother about it and it's like you
know we kind of got to the got to the
conclusion of
it's not worth it you know you don't
want to end up dealing with criminal
charges or ending up in jail or whatever
happens happens right it's like yeah
it's just no it's not worth it so it was
at that point that that scammer that
ripped me off
for 15 grand about half of what i would
normally make in a given month and i had
payroll to do that day
so i actually didn't even pay myself at
that time to make sure the payroll
cleared so i got my staff taken care of
and i was like ready to do something to
this guy and i'm like nope nope i'm
marinating on it i was like
i'm not going to lose here like this
like there's got to be a silver lining
you know you guys have heard there's a
silver lining in in every piece of piece
of chaos out there
and there's these stories about
fragility
robustness and anti-fragility um i think
it comes from nicholas talib i probably
got the combination of his name wrong
but it's something like that anyway he
wrote a book called anti-fragile and
there's three levels of fragility
there's
um
you know i could take a glass for
example so if i take this glass over
here and i were to drop it from
sufficient height it's it's fragile it's
going to break my drink's gonna go all
over the floor so that's what fragility
is
robustness would be something like uh
i don't know this box for my ledger it's
like nothing happens if i drop it it
doesn't break it doesn't get better it
doesn't get worse nothing happens it's
robust that would be like a bag of sand
dropping a bag saying you know same sort
of thing
and then there's anti-fragility which
means you only get better
when chaos is applied to something i
don't have any example of anything here
that would improve if i added chaos or
stress to it but that's something that's
unique to human beings humans can
actually get better
when there's chaos introduced into their
life
and that book wasn't out at the time i
think that book came out about seven or
eight years later because i remember
listening to it
um actually i did a review on that book
in my car in the early days of the
channel so if you search on my youtube
channel for entrepreneurs and cars
anti-fragile i think you'll find it i
was probably driving the m3 at the time
i did a lot of book reviews back then so
there's some interesting ones anyway so
i figured out i got to use this as an
opportunity to grow you know don't lose
learn and i kept telling myself that
over and over again don't lose learn
don't lose learn i'm like how the [ __ ]
do i make sure this isn't happening and
this guy ripped me off for half of my
monthly
sales receipts
i
i couldn't pay myself that day so i had
to pay the staff only and it's like
okay
so i went
so i went on a pretty much like a
48-hour binge looking for potential
solutions
and i've used the term r d for you guys
before
r d isn't research and development is
rip off and duplicate quite often
the solutions to many of our problems as
guys already exist out there you just
have to be attentive enough to know how
to go find them
right and then execute that [ __ ]
methodically with precision
so
that's what i did um i found software
and i pivoted the business from doing
lump sums taking the deals from mortgage
agents one of the other problems i ended
up dealing with the mortgage agents is
a good number of them would try to do it
themselves right like they would
actually
um
figure out that on top of doing
getting their brokers fee for
facilitating the mortgage payment which
might have been
anywhere from three to six thousand
dollars for them on average at that time
they could also charge the customer
money to go and negotiate that so it's
like i was basically training my
competition because they also knew a lot
of the inside stuff so i was like okay i
need to put some distance between this
type of deal
so i got rid of that kind of customer
for the most part and also instead of
going
to get my customers from mortgage agents
i went directly to get the customer
here's how i did it
i'm like how do i find my customer so i
did things like fax broadcasting i tried
fax broadcasting i tried ads like i
showed you that newspaper i tried out
adds a newspaper i did radio [ __ ] um but
the stuff that really worked well um for
a good period of time it still works
okay today not as well as it did back in
the day was
um pay-per-click ad marketing through
google adwords
um i got really good at that and within
maybe a couple years like i was top in
the space like i was like my conversion
rates were super high they were like
triple the
with the other guys in the industry
we're getting and the cost for
acquisition was very very uh cheap
there was a lot of margin at the time
so i went from not being able to pay
myself on payday and getting [ __ ] over
by a guy that i couldn't do anything
about i had
no legal remedy um
i could have potentially sued him but i
don't even remember the status of the
um contract at the time and i probably
wouldn't have had the money to pay a
lawyer to be honest with you because it
would have probably cost about 20 grand
minimum in fees to get anywhere close to
getting him to cough up the cash and
even then i may not have even gotten
paid so it's just like it was a loss
leader
and i've done that a few times in life i
mean i lost 46 000 on a mortgage deal
once
um this guy did pay me 15 grand like you
get screwed over in life as a guy when
you start taking risks especially when
you're running a business especially
when you get involved
um you know in matters of uh finance
there's
it's gonna happen it doesn't happen that
often but it does happen right
so
to the point of that
what i ended up doing after that is i
basically went from killing from from
eating what i killed i guess basically
is a best way to define it so when an
animal goes out hunting
you kill it you eat it the meat's good
for maybe a day i don't know what the
total window is let's say it's a day and
then you have to go out and do it all
over again right so you're so you're
always eating what you kill
and
i had some inkling about what was going
on with cell phone contracts at the time
because i just think to myself you know
the cell phone company does really good
like i had one of those old ass nokias
they were like a brick this is 2005 or
six
and um
you know i was like you know they're
collecting 27 a month for me every
single month and i keep using the
service and how many customers they have
and they keep using the service i'm like
recurring revenue is way better because
you open up the door at the start of the
month and you know exactly what's coming
in
right you know it's a budget for
marketing you know how um you know
basically how things are going to unfold
that month
so i essentially pivoted the business
from
um one-off
deals to a subscription revenue model
which basically built a book a book of
business which i had offers to buy from
me
um
but essentially you know we build a
large book of business
and that's what
that that one guy that that [ __ ] me
over for 15 grand in 2005
forced me to take a look at
alternatives one of them you know could
have been could have put me in jail or
you know maybe done something stupid so
i took a good look at alternatives and i
found a way to make more money over a
longer period of time
and take on more clients with the same
amount of um head count staff staffing
basically
um
and it was after that the business took
off it it it just blew up like i think
our biggest months were um maybe 300 000
a month in like sales receipts we had
over a thousand customers
um
and over a long period of time too so
they were paying over not just like a
few months or a few weeks like i was
before but generally speaking about four
years
so you just took the total fee you broke
it down over four years and you had the
subscription revenue model
good thing about that is it's sellable
somebody may want to buy your book of
business they may want to buy your
business because it already has
customers that are making payments so
attractive businesses to to buy have
recurring revenue netflix you know for
example has customers that are
subscribed they pay whatever it is a
month you know depending on their plan
and then that recurring revenue you know
multiplied by the number of customers
they have making the payments is now
called the book of business and somebody
could come along and say right we'll
give you
10 million dollars for that 100 million
whatever it's worth
and they
that's when businesses sell like that's
why these tech companies always look for
users so they can say like youtube right
now is is gonna say well we have
x number of eyeballs on our platform
every single day
they we have the attention of these
people so subscription revenue beautiful
that's why they call
subscribers on youtube right because you
know you subscribe for the content
youtube unfortunately doesn't generally
send it to you you have to like
subscribe hit the notification bell and
even that doesn't work half the time you
have to go and search for the damn
channel to watch the [ __ ] that you want
because they don't want to show it to
you but another story so
that guy made me a multi-millionaire
that guy that [ __ ] me over made me a
multi-millionaire so think about that
um there's a book by ryan halliday i
don't like some of his other books but
it's called the obstacle is away i think
it's a great book i think it
is something that you should read if
you're a guy you should definitely read
it if you're an entrepreneur because it
gets you thinking about turning
obstacles into solutions often obstacles
can become the way you can go around it
you can dig under it you can push it out
of the way there's a whole bunch of
different ways to handle things
sometimes you could
you know turn the obstacle into the way
you know for example so there's
different ways to handle it so that was
the that was the first one that i wanted
to drop on you guys hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you